hey what's up everyone it's Warren and
today we got the Avengers Prelude number
3 the final Prelude before Avengers in
game comes out the preludes that Marvel
due for their upcoming movies in the MCU
usually provide us with a little bit
more insight of what we can expect for
the upcoming movie however the avengers
endgame prelude to number 1 and number 2
didn't really provide us with any new
information at all in fact they were
just recaps of what happened in Avengers
infinity war so there was hope for
prelude number 3 that we would get a
little bit of new information of what to
expect in Avengers in game but sadly it
is again mostly just a recap however
there are a few scenes that I would like
to talk about because I do believe
they'll play a part in Avengers endgame
Prelude number three is pretty much the
third part of Avengers infinity war
it has Tony Stark Doctor Strange and
Peter Parker meeting some of the
guardians of the galaxy on a beanie
mashup and then going to Titan to fight
Thanos thou'rt rocket and Groot go to
neduvaali R to find Eitri to forge
Stormbreaker and this is one of the
parts that i want to talk about because
there is some added extra dialogue in
this comic that is not in the movie when
Thor restarts Netivot lair he looks the
rocket and he says that's neduvaali r
the renowned forge capable of crafting
legendary weapons including the one
we'll use to avenge my people in the
movie he only looks at rocket and says
that's neduvaali r but in the comic he
talks about how it's used for forging
legendary weapons it is widely believed
that there will be a second legendary
weapon in Avengers in game because III
actually had two molds made many people
think that it's a second Stormbreaker
but this added line puts a emphasis on
legendary weapons so perhaps we'll see
Thor return to neduvaali ER to get
another legendary weapon to take on
Thanos it then goes back to all the
heroes on Titan and Doctor Strange going
forward in time to see the 14 million
605 different scenarios we then go with
fan oohs and Gomorrha on vermeer and
this is another scene that I really want
to stress here because I do think it
could play a big part in avengers
endgame Thanos and Gamora are greeted by
Red Skull and Red Skull explains the
sacrifice required to obtain the soul
stone Red Skull explains that the soul
stone holds
special place among the Infinity stones
and that it has a certain wisdom and
demands a sacrifice of course
Thanos ends up sacrificing Gamora but
Red Skull says to him your will is
strong Thanos the Stone accepts your
sacrifice he's talking about the Stone
like it's a living being and it has a
consciousness which we know they kind of
are and know they kind of do we know
that the mine stone talked a vision and
Avengers infinity war multiple times and
do we know that the mine Stone
influenced Loki in the first Avengers
film so the Infinity stones are alive
and they can sort of think and feel
because Red Skull saying that the Stone
accepts Thanos as sacrifice means that
it could have denied it it does truly
know if your sacrifice is the one thing
you love the most
this will make it very difficult for the
Avengers to retrieve the soul stone in
Avengers endgame which means that one of
the Avengers will have to make that
ultimate sacrifice I also do think that
the Infinity stones being somewhat alive
will play a factor in avengers endgame
I've already done a bunch of theories of
who could be inside the Infinity stones
or what the soul stones could be I won't
really jump into it now but I do think
that it will come into play in Avengers
in game then we have the rest of the
Avengers arriving in Wakanda to try and
take the mind stone out of vision and
also prepare for an attack by Thanos the
rest of the prelude goes exactly as the
movie goes almost word-for-word but they
did include another stand soapbox
message that of course I'll go over
it's from July 1967 and it reads this is
as good a place as any to thank you once
more for being the most wonderful fans
any publishing company ever had
if Marvel is on top of the heap it's
your support that put us there if Marvel
gives you the type of mags you want it's
your letters that have told us how and
if Marvel occasionally comes up with a
clinker go hang your head hero whatever
we are you've made us we've had a lot of
laughs together and a lot of excitement
and the best is still ahead so face
front frantic 1 Marvel's on the March
and we're not taking a step without you
on behalf of the entire batty bullpen to
true believers everywhere we'll never
let you down because you're the
ever-loving greatest so that's it for
the Avengers in game Prelude number
three again nothing really new but there
could be a few important parts in there
that we could see in Avengers endgame so
let me know your thoughts on this and
the
it's down below and I'm still giving
away five IMAX tickets if you'd like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
[Music]